okay
that's an improvement
[Music]
[Music]
hey there folks so uh before we get to
the review proper um i have something
that i need to say and it's something
that i'm going to continue to say for as
long as i deem it to be necessary uh the
bbc in particular the news arm of the
bbc is a transphobic organization that
continually platforms transphobes
including recently a woman who called
out for outright genocide against trans
women and they have yet to address the
fact that they did that
so um
screw them and if you don't know what
the hell i'm talking about
there's the link to a video where i
explain it in detail i'm not going to
bog it down further in here but i am
going to point it out every time i talk
about something bbc owned and yes i
understand the difference between bbc
news and the bbc creative department
don't care this is [ __ ]
that now having been said
war of the santarans as i said in the
cold open this is better this is
actually
a lot better
i'm not sure it's
great it's decent and it definitely um
is sorting a lot of the problems i had
last time not in the sense that it
suddenly fixes or retroactively improves
the issues that i had last time but
those issues are not repeating to the
same degree and in order to explain that
i need to put a little bit of context
and also offer a slight meh culpa to
some of my criticisms and critiques in
the previous episode now i did
fail to remember
that the division was something that was
established back with the timeless child
the thing is though i haven't rewatched
the timeless child i don't have the
energy to try and re-watch the timeless
child and i did not remember
what the organization
that the fugitive doctor was tied to
introduced way back in fugitive of the
jedu even though that's an episode i
liked haven't rewatched i haven't
rewatched series 12 at all at this point
um other than uh can you hear me that's
the only one i've seen more than once so
the fact that
i did not remember that is partially on
me so me not realizing the way that i
still i will never get his name right so
i'm still gonna go with the dog alien
the way that the doctor's pursuit of him
ties into that story thread
is there i said it wasn't it was because
i did not remember that the division was
the name of that in my defense unless
you've re-watched series 12 recently or
are seriously invested in the timeless
child which i am not
then i think that's the kind of thing
that previously on segments are built to
remind you of and it
didn't but even setting that aside this
has a structure to it that is basically
what i said i wish the previous one had
one of the things i said about the
halloween apocalypse was there was no
central core that everything was built
around technically you could say that
everything tied to the flux but that's
just a that was just a logistical string
the flux didn't feel like a central
focus it was a thing that was happening
in addition to the skull-faced aliens
the swarm and azure uh showing up in
addition to the dog alien in addition to
the santarans in addition to dan getting
introduced in addition to vendor getting
introduced it was just one more thing on
the pile and while it was attempted to
give it more weight by making it the
threat
not anything really tied back to
anything more than a very superficial
way and the way the story is structured
it was not given any more
or
what was her name claire and the
weeping angel i'll reiterate there was
too much packed into that previous
episode and there really wasn't a clear
central thing that everything else was
working around the closest thing it had
was dan and the dog alien but we didn't
know why any of that was happening so
all we had was questions while more
questions were being piled on by all the
other stuff being introduced here
we have the santarans taking over earth
that is the core that is the central
pillar around which everything else
revolves and it works
so
much
better
i'm not saying you can't have multiple
elements but one of them especially on a
per-story basis needs to be the primary
one i really do not feel that anything
was clearly the primary thing that we
were dealing with in the previous
episode here it definitely is
no question santarans are the key thing
and actually i was really enjoying this
a lot up until about halfway point when
the series villains presumably swarm and
azure showed up and because i find them
actually incredibly generic but you know
what stick a pen and then we'll come
back to them but the idea of the
centaurus in general using a temporal
displacement to not only take over earth
but basically took over earth
retroactively so that it's always been
theirs
is a nifty idea i love that there is a
ref i love that the motivation is done
as a reference to the very first
appearance of the centaurus which is the
time warrior which is one of my favorite
classic doctor who stories and they
reference commander lynx claiming the
planet which is one of the best moments
from that episode if you haven't seen it
he steps out of his little
his little spaceship pod and just plants
this flag this one centaurin no fleet
tobacco velvety just shows up and goes i
claim this for the sontaran empire and
it's great and i love the idea that they
still believe that gives them a claim on
the planet and they're coming to simply
make good on that that is more than
sufficient motivation especially for a
species like the santarans as
regimented and pigheaded as they are
that is spot on now do we really get an
explanation as to why they are the older
style as opposed to the new one no but
you know what i think i kind of said
previously it'd be nice to have an
explanation at this point having sat
with it a week actually no we don't need
it and also it makes the connection to
links stronger since this is the design
more reminiscent of that very first
appearance of the very first ontarian
character in the show so i liked that
already right off the bat it's just
relieving to see the centaurus be
something other than a background
punchline there are still comedic
moments here mostly to do with the
santaran that was um being healed and
then released some of the interactions
there but it's it's always make clear
that they are a threat well i say that i
think the sontarens probably rivaled the
imperial stormtroopers as the worst
shots in the galaxy when dan was running
away from a freaking little platoon of
them they were like i don't know how
many there were like at least four it
felt like six i don't know i didn't
count but there's a bunch of them
shooting at him and he is not really
dodging he's not even running that fast
he just kind of
and they they can't hit him
really and then later when um dan and
the dog alien are on their ship and they
open the door and the stunters are there
and start shooting at them and you're
like you're three feet away and you're
missing
uh
yay that i don't love because that's
that's
that's a very standard contrivance in
well
basically any story that has heroes and
the enemies have guns they're always
going to miss but like this felt like it
drew attention to how bad a shots they
were like i didn't love that i did think
it was interesting that for setting in
the crimean crimean war and around the
same time as florence nightingale who
gets a name drop they focused on mary
seacole who was someone who i had not
heard of and i kind of like that they
picked a setting that i had heard of
referenced a historical figure that i
had heard of but presented me with a
historical figure who i didn't know now
given my normal attitude towards the um
let's have a famous person from history
show up stories this is actually a
decent way to thread the needle and
avoid the issues that i tend to have
which is that they tend to be just very
over aggrandizing of these you know
great figures of history whereas
mary segal comes across as much more
human i mean a little idealized yeah
probably but it didn't feel like i got a
massive wikipedia dump about her we got
a couple of details of information about
her enough for me to go oh okay and then
to on my own time look up more about her
go oh okay that she was an interesting
person cool i kind of like that idea
that instead of giving me a famous
figure that i already know a ton about
like winston churchill or queen victoria
or what have you
or giving me someone who maybe i know
some about but then vomiting a wikipedia
entry at me like with um
or whatever king it was in uh the witch
hunters i'm not gonna bother to look it
up i don't care but
but rather than doing those giving me
someone who you give me just enough
information that if i want to find out
more you gave me enough information to
be able to look them up and find out
what i want on my own time that's much
better balanced than doctor who often
does and in particular has been under
the chibnall era so decently done there
now i had set aside um
swarm and azure
uh
here's the here's the problem with them
for me right now is that they are very
very
generic
they are very
you cannot stop me i am in control style
villains which
is not my favorite kind of villain in
the first place uh personally speaking
just personal preference but in addition
to that
given that doctor who has a
very lengthy history of
villains with that template of a
personality
i don't know i i i i'm gonna spend a
decent chunk of my time until i
spot something that solidifies it
wondering
why this couldn't have been existing
villains why this couldn't have been
tied to
omega
sutek
the master heck the great intelligence
even
you know the the general personality is
not so far distinct from those others
heck they're honestly reminding me a lot
of the
godlike beings from can you hear me
and i know most people don't like can
you hear me i know i'm in a minority on
that but like
chris
mr chibnall you you've introduced
characters that are like this already
and you're introducing more that fit the
same mold now there may be a reason most
likely a
logistical narrative reason why it had
to be new ones and there's something
about them that
uh pre-existing characters wouldn't have
worked in maybe i'll be keeping an eye
out for whether or not that's the case
if it never manifests i'm gonna i'm
gonna count that as a fault
to because
look there's nothing wrong with
introducing new villains there is a
problem with introducing new villains
who fit a template that existing
villains could have filled just as well
with no detriment to the story will
there be detriments to the story i don't
know i need to find out more about them
before i get any of that down i'm
strongly suspecting at this point that
this the planet time and the i can't i
can never
chip no i can never remember the names
of any of the species you
come up with but whatever the heck
um they were called is somehow going to
be tied into the doctor as
the timeless child thing
that's my presumption at this point
we'll see now here's the thing as much
as i enjoyed this episode certainly a
heck of a lot more than the previous one
and while not without my issues most of
those tied to the overall thing and less
so with the episode in and of itself
honestly if this had been a completely
standalone sontaran story without the
ties to the greater flux thing i
probably would have liked it a lot
i love that the centaur and commander
picked the time period because he wanted
to ride a horse
that's a gorgeous detail i love it i
also buy it
um but
it's like it's a quirk we've got quirks
don't overload somebody with quirks but
you know i i like that
but the thing is
that
right now structurally as for something
being sold as a quote-unquote serialized
story
what we've gotten so far
is an episode that was overstuffed with
nothing but setup and had no central
story to speak of
followed by something that had a very
clear central story but a central story
that could have been standalone to no
particular detriment
so
the sense that i'm getting at this point
as to how chibnall is approaching this
as a serialized story
is to
have the flux be the mechanism that
connects
various more or less standalone stories
which kind of puts it in mind um
not dissimilar to say the key to time
back in the tom baker era
it i i would say there's a bit more uh
connective tissue to this than the risk
of the key to time that is legitimately
just an excuse to connect a bunch of
otherwise completely unconnected stories
so
like don't get me wrong it's more
connected than that but if what we saw
this episode is what is going to become
standard for the series
it's not bad but
serialized feels honestly kind of like
overselling it because this isn't really
about this
about uh
80 of this you could watch without
knowing what's going on the rest of the
series and get some enjoyment out of it
i'm not sure i'd call it serialized
um not entirely at any rate i suppose
it's a little bit more connected than
episodic but
not by much
it's it's dwelling right now in an odd
middle space and i'm kind of going to
deal with this a little bit um later on
this month i actually want to do a video
sort of breaking down the positives and
negatives of episodic versus serialized
storytelling and the distinctions
between them besides you know the
obvious textbook definitions that it's
not going to be strictly about doctor
who although clearly doctor who will be
the reason i've been thinking about this
stuff
but it's
i wish
and like here's the thing i
maybe
this is partially on me because i i was
avoiding a lot of the
um the pre-release
news i don't know if chibnall
talked in interviews or anything like
that and said
exactly how this was going to be
structured and put together so it is
possible that maybe he said somewhere
along the line there's going to be a
connecting story but many of the
episodes will be more or less standalone
maybe he said that i wasn't looking it
up i generally don't look up a ton of
that kind of stuff about things in
advance mainly in the interest of trying
to avoid spoilers so i have a tendency
to take in trailers and as little else
as i can get away with unless it's
something so big that i can't ignore it
so
i don't know if he said anything like
that but
whether or not he did or he didn't as a
viewer i'm coming out this kind of
feeling like
i i wonder if i would be having a better
overall viewing experience if i'd had a
clear idea of exactly
how this thing is going to be structured
so that i had a better idea of what to
expect
because what i feel like i was told
going in was serialized and as
serialized storytelling a lot of people
last episode seemed to use it as an
excuse for why the episode didn't have
to make sense because it was only part
of a complete story except it was
released as a standalone episode it has
to do something and the main issue i had
with it was it lacked that clear central
story to base everything else around or
at least i certainly feel that it did
but then it goes into this which is
closer to episodic with continuous
elements but i wouldn't call this
serialized from the previous episode
so i'm not entirely sure what this
overall thing is
like i said it seems to be in this weird
middle ground and maybe it'll work out
but i kind of wish i'd known that going
in
but again maybe that's something maybe
they said and i wasn't paying attention
it's an improvement
in any case regardless this is an
improvement over the previous one
i'm not going to say that necessarily
improves my expectations for the next
episode because well a couple of reasons
uh we've had the dog alien it appears at
least for the time being depart the
story until later i liked him so i'm
like oh
hmm
and it looks like we're going to get
more focus on
swarm and azure which you know hopefully
means they'll become more interesting to
me
but
given how generic they feel i don't have
a ton of hope for that so i'm not
looking forward to something that's
going to focus more
on them and who they are i mean
i'm curious in a strictly i mean i guess
i might as well know what's going on
sense but not uh not super curious in a
uh oh i must know the answer kind of way
but that's where i am right now
it's definitely better than the last one
you know what for right now
i'll take it
war of the sun taurens what'd you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it like share subscribe i have a
patreon that is how i pay my bills keep
this whole operation up and running um
and any amount you're able to give there
is of great assistance there's also
youtube memberships people want to go
that way as well but
no big pressure on that because at the
end of the day my friends you are the
council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and look at you sticking around through
the credits i appreciate that well you
know what you're about to be treated to
a whole ton of names going by on the
screen but
there's a few of them that i want to
give special attention to my special
thanks to bookworm jared boyce mj tracy
scrabbit vincent paul bartolucci caitlin
schwartz edelen hannah acker robin moore
ross schultz and shayla gourley if you
want to hear me mispronounce your name
check out the reward tiers on the
patreon but for right now
thanks so much
[Music]
um
[Music]